de nombreux cas de kobe de 19
enregistrée à new delhi la capitale
traverse une situation sanitaire plus
que jamais préoccupante
un pic de contamination qui
s'expliquerait notamment par la saison
des festivals selon le ministère de la
santé
le 14 novembre prochain la fête
populaire hindoue de diwali ci doit se
tenir à travers le pays
des célébrations qui ont pour habitude
de durer plusieurs jours d'affilée
les indiens redoute le manque de
précaution de la population
si vous ne prenez pas de précaution
pendant le festival des lumières les
autres festivals à venir le nouvel an il
ya de fortes chances que les cas
augmentent encore
donc si nous n'adhérons pas la
distanciation sociale ce sera très
dangereux
ce sera difficile à contrôler les cas
augmentent parce que les gens sont
devenus négligent si vous allez sur les
marchés vous verrez qu'il ya de grandes
foules
les gens ne porte pas de masque ils
mangent au restaurant de son côté le
ministère de la santé a prévenu d'une
possible aggravation de la situation
dans les prochains jours de nombreux
indiens devraient affluer vers les
marchés pour les achats liés aux
festivités un contexte particulier
auquel viennent s'ajouter l'arrivée de
l'hiver et des niveaux élevés de
pollution atmosphérique dans la capitale
deux facteurs susceptibles d'aggraver la
pandémie